[Music]
[Applause]
we're getting together to talk about all
the things we used to do
the laughs the passions the little
sebastians the pets were failing
and we're putting it all in a podcast
then we'll send it up into the sky
we're calling it parks and recollection
come on little podcast spread your wings
and fly
hello
everybody
welcome
to parks and recollection what's up
what's up that's my pal right there
that's alan yang ladies and germs happy
to be here happy to talk about the show
happy to talk to you rob for those of
you who don't know the great alan yang
alan yang wrote on parks and recreation
from day one and later we'll get into
this was a kind of the inspiration for
chris trager would that's that's a fair
assessment of your contribution wouldn't
you say it's somewhat fair i would say i
was a writer on the show for all 125
episodes and there are definitely
elements of chris uh in my personality
because uh we're both very high energy
people and uh relentlessly positive
hopefully not annoyingly so but uh yeah
listeners will be the judge of that yeah
we'll see as they uh as everybody comes
into this little club we've started i'm
excited to have you guys listening this
is fasten your seatbelts
going to be the ultimate parks and
recreation
experience
and we're just going to spend some time
on a show that alan and i worked on and
loved yeah it's also nice to go back and
look at a show like you know
there's no mono culture anymore man not
everyone's watching the same shows but
like back when this show was airing and
the office was airing 30 rock people
would watch shows on one night like
thursday night people would watch
television community was on that night
too he's like can you remember a time i
think the last show like that was game
of thrones it just does wait are you are
you asking me if i can remember a time
when tv was good is that what you're
asking me because it sounds like what
you're asking i'm not saying i'm not
saying it's not good but it's just a
it's just a warm funny familial show and
it is it you know every time we see each
other again or or people from the cast
and other writers we do talk about it
because it's also this formative
experience right you're just spending
time with these cast members and these
writers every day every day and the show
ran for seven years so few shows run
that long anymore so we really were like
a family and if you ever watched the
show and you felt the tone of the show
and the warmth and the sort of you know
the camaraderie that was all because the
writer's room and the cast were all kind
of like that in real life i hate to
disappoint anyone looking for horrible
gossip because we just loved each other
too much i think it came across in the
show so it's going to be really fun to
watch these episodes i haven't seen a
lot of them in a long time so we're
starting from scratch man we're starting
from the pilot and and it's cool to see
them again and and see how the show
changed over time alan how would you
describe my performance in the pilot
just getting started it is
powerful i would say i think uh
award-worthy i believe you were
nominated for seven emmys for your
performance in the pilot no chris
traeger is not in the pilot rob's not in
the pilot he's watching these as a fan
so we're gonna talk about the show i
think it's gonna be really interesting
because rob is gonna you know he shows
up in season two season one is really
short it's six episodes and we're gonna
burn through him just watch these
episodes and talk about how the show
changed and rob is gonna be able to
offer his opinion because when he joined
the show the characters had changed a
little bit and the show had kind of
found a groove and so um it's gonna be
fun to sort of watch them me someone
who's worked on them and rob is someone
who is kind of watching them if not for
the first time then sort of well
sometimes for the first time what about
that rob i mean well listen i and we'll
get into more of this as we progress but
i watched the pilot last night
i'd never seen it before
and i have so many thoughts
for you sir
let's let's describe the show this way
parks and rec is a dead body and we are
quincy yeah we are doing an autopsy
on each episode of parks and recreation
yeah we're really excited to do this
podcast and we're giving you a rundown
of what each episode is gonna feel like
we're gonna kick off each episode of
parks and recollection with a recap of
the episode we're gonna discuss just a
little summary then we're gonna tell you
about all the juicy details about what
happens behind the scenes the writing
process the casting the props all that
stuff members of our cast and crew will
be stopping by along the way
and then we'll close out each episode
with what we like to call the pawnee
town hall where we answer your fan
questions so send them in
and now that you know what the deal is i
think we're ready to kick this off and
get going